bonjour je m'appelle Jean-David Denard
je représente la société amolux donc je
vais vous présenter rapidement ma
société je suis conducteur de travaux de
formation j'ai travaillé dans le
bâtiment amolux c'est une agence de
d'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvrage
c'est-à-dire que j'aide mes clients à
définir leur projet en fonction de leur
budget je les aide à faire leur plan
donc à déposer ensuite le permis de
construire ensuite je choisis les
entreprises avec eux je suis je fais
ensuite tout ce qui est suivi et
coordination des travaux je vais mettre
en place un planning pour mon client
donc comme ça les délais sont respectés
je vais faire tout le suivi financier du
chantier avec le client je vais faire
une gestion comptable pour le client
donc client saura exactement ce qu' va
payer à quel moment je contrôle
également les situations de travaux qui
sont demandées par les entreprises je
valide en fonction de l'avancement des
travaux je me suis inscrit dans le dans
la catégorie
insertion parce que j'ai fait une
reconversion professionnelle j'étais à
la base en licence de
STAPS ça a pas fonctionné comme je
voulais parce que c'était pas vraiment
ma voix donc un moment donné j'ai fait
une reconversion professionnelle par
rapport à un événement qui s'est passé
dans ma vie et j'ai décidé de créer mon
entreprise et mon étude de marché m'a
permis de voir justement que les clients
ont besoin d'aide ils ont besoin d'être
accompagnés et que leur projet de
construction qui est le projet d'une vie
en fait soit maîtrisé et qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui suiv vraiment qui est un
professionnel extérieur au aux
entreprises qui font la maison qui gèent
pour eux et qui les accompagnent bah
dans leur projet d'une vie
quoi